russia's grinding onslaught in eastern
ukraine is taking a bloody toll
ukraine's president says this will go
down in history as one of the most
brutal battles europe has seen
with russian forces bearing down on the
key city of sieviero donetsk kiev was
receiving top eu leaders
and all the while
turkey's president seeks to cast himself
as mediator while simultaneously putting
pressure on nato
today we ask turkey's double dealing is
erdogan trying to blackmail the west
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it is
a pleasure to introduce our guests
daniel gerlach is editor-in-chief of the
magazine zenith and director of the
think tank candid foundation
also a great pleasure to welcome gustav
kressel he is senior policy fellow at
the berlin office of the european
council on foreign relations
and jessica berlin is with us she's
founder and managing director of the
strategic analysis consultancy co-struct
and jessica if i may i'd like to start
out with the current situation in
eastern ukraine military experts say
that more than a hundred ukrainian
soldiers are dying every day in what has
become a grinding war of attrition
thousands of civilians are trapped now
in the epicenter in the city of sierra
de vero donetsk what if anything could
end this bloodshed is a negotiated
solution even conceivable
at this point unfortunately not the only
thing that can end this onslaught is
increased artillery power for the
ukrainian side
the russian military will only respond
to deterrence they know that they can
steamroll ahead with their superior
artillery firepower and superior air
power
and simply inch by inch meter by meter
village by village crush the ukrainian
military's resistance and as bravely as
the ukrainians have fought and are
fighting every day they simply do not
have the hardware to stand up to the
russian army and so this is why
the calls for immediate and vast
delivery of heavy weapons to ukraine is
so critical because every day counts at
this point
gustav let me ask you ukraine's
president has actually been defying a
russian ultimatum that he uh surrendered
uh in donetsk and says that only
ukrainian victory could provide the
basis for any form of settlement is that
a realistic goal or is it wishful
thinking
well
the problem is without without a
lifeline in the west
in terms of munitions in terms of
equipment
unfortunately a ukrainian victory
will will not commend ukraine's arms
industry has been destroyed
by and large
there is no chance to make good for
losses in the war if one does not get
weapons from abroad
negotiated settlement i think is a big
illusion in the west
any
thing that would fall short of driving
russia back
to the borders to the administrative
boundaries before the before february
24th will be seen
by russia as a partial victory and
a state from where to push further once
uh russia has regrouped re-armed regand
uh we saw the same with the previous
minsk iteration of ceasefire first of
all it wasn't a ceasefire second of all
it just paused the war
and made russia onslaught now if the
russians would get that now they will
try again in three four years i want to
come back to
those latter points but let me first ask
daniel also about these latest appeals
that we are hearing from president
zielenski he's basically uh saying what
we've just heard the only way that the
ukraine will win this war is with
massive additional deliveries of heppy
weapons and he's calling for artillery
how it serves battle tanks drones the
u.s has just announced an additional
billion dollars in security supplies
should europe follow suit
um
certainly europe should follow um
the only problem is like do you really
find the will in the among the political
leaders in europe to take on the
long-term consequences of course the the
europeans are very much like when they
look at the at the american position
they say like okay you are far away
you're far away from the situation but
we we bear the consequences or like
after the ukrainians we are the next
ones to bear the consequences so do you
conclude from that
that uh that's why you should lead and
that's why you should actually do more
than the americans or that's why you
should still hope for a negotiated uh
for for for what you call an illusion uh
a negotiated solution i think one should
take on putin's strategy in a certain
way which is
at the same time
negotiate and fight and deliver weapons
because only trusting or only relying on
negotiations diplomatic negotiations i
totally agree i don't see that but
not keeping negotiations out of sight
and not completely abandoning the
diplomatic track as i think i think
something that is that is uh recommended
and it's also something that the
europeans in one way or the other
uh apply
if i can respond to that
negotiations the door should always be
open absolutely
but the point is
vladimir putin will only come to the
negotiating table willing to back down
willing to compromise and give ukraine
and the west something we want
if he is facing
loss if he's facing deterrence
right now the fact that we have leaders
we have president macron and chancellor
schultz making phone calls to putin
calling for dialogue
this is feeding right into putin's
strategy and furthermore when we talk
about public opinion and the notion of
what's at stake what's going to happen
to us if we deliver more heavy weapons
the problem is actually the reverse
if russia wins this war if russia is
allowed to defeat ukraine to murder tens
of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of more people innocent
civilians
and annex an entire country that was
free and independent and european
if they're allowed to do this
and emerge from this victorious the
costs
geopolitically economically for europe
and the rest of the world will be
disastrous it will be much much worse if
we let russia win
at the cost of ukraine and near-term
perceived benefit or less stress for us
than if we consequently help ukraine to
defeat this threat and to say that this
can no longer happen in europe this is
the 21st century and might is no longer
making right
those phone calls that you mentioned uh
between chancellor schultz uh emmanuel
macron the french president and vladimir
putin have in fact been strongly
criticized by a number of those
countries closest allies germany has
been accused of equivocating on its own
support for ukraine promising heavy
weapons but failing to deliver as
chancellor schultz was preparing to
travel to kiev president zielenski
issued a new appeal
we need assurances from chancellor
schultz that germany supports ukraine
he and his government have to make a
decision
they should not try to find a balance
between ukraine and their relationship
with russia ukraine
gustav would you say that chancellor
schultz has exercised excessive
caution and if so why what do you think
are his motives
uh yes he has exercised excessive
caution uh and
i mean some of the rationale
of these calls are understandable to
kind of see where the russians are what
their interests are what they would be
willing to do or not to do the problem
is of course if you negotiate with the
counterpart especially with a former
intelligence officer that they will of
course not
negotiate in good faith and they will
not tell you the truth they will also
try to probe you to manipulate you to
tell you things from
that they expect that putin expects
to
make schultz do what he wants and on
this game
putin is far more successful than all of
schultz uh the the whole
issue of world war three and the scare
of russian nukes that's psychological
warfare and schultz has completely
fallen for the russian trap
and it is still something that putin has
sort of is shaping schultz's minds when
it comes to the risks and consequences
of this war this is exactly why
eastern europeans have
called this calls
to be dangerous they have not criticized
for example angela merkel's calls to
putin in the same way because she coming
from eastern germany has much more
experience reading former communist
intelligence characters which is part of
your skill portfolio you need if you
reach out to people like putin
i'm no expert on psychology nor in
russia
but what i hear let's say from political
circles in paris and in berlin is that
what's what's what's one of the reasons
why they're keeping this line of
communication is because
they want to feel the temperature of
putin's mental health
it's not just about about
trying to assuage him to talk into
something
to to talk him into compromise
i think
german
government
intelligence and security experts are
worried about how protein is going to go
and if they if and if they cut this this
this rope this line of communication
they are worried that he might go even
further
and they would be taken by surprise i
don't know if that is a a logical
assessment of the situation but at least
i think it is totally understandable i'm
not defending forces or macron's
position and putin i know that macron
for a long time had the illusion that he
could he could read putin and all his
political advisors were like you're
delusional you're not going to do this
and you're weak in face of this man but
nevertheless i totally understand that
as a head of state you considered your
obligation
not to abandon the path of diplomacy
with the country that owns possesses i
don't know 6 300 nuclear warheads if
it's going to use them or not is another
question and that's it isn't it
i saw you nodding when gustav was
talking essentially about putin playing
the fear card and that fear card
includes very lightly veiled threats of
the potential use of tactical nuclear
weapons
how should the west respond when you
hear emmanuel macron saying after one of
these phone calls we shouldn't humiliate
putin would you say jessica that is the
right response
vladimir putin has already humiliated
himself first and foremost he thought
this war was going to be over in three
days
well guess what it's almost four months
in and ukraine is still standing and
standing strong
so
any notion of saving putin's face is is
farcical and
honestly when i heard macron make this
statement about not humiliating putin i
had the sense that maybe it's about not
humiliating mr macron
he went on his
very high profile diplomatic mission to
moscow before the war began said i'm
going to sit down with vladimir putin
and talk to him make him see reason
well that didn't work and and it's
exactly what gustav was saying before
vladimir putin
has a much better measure of the men in
high office here in western europe than
our leaders have of him he's been in
this game for a very long time he's much
more experienced in psyops
and psychological operations
psychological operations yeah i mean our
leaders have zero experience in this
and this is a tactical weakness that
russia is also playing with
putin knows that the egos of our leaders
can be manipulated for his aims he also
knows that the fears of our voters and
our democracies are for him a weapon he
can use by spreading fear in the
population he can ensure that our
democratic institutions and leaders have
to respond to those fears and the number
one thing that our leaders in western
europe would need to do to assuage those
fears is have a clear conversation
with the public with the people of
germany of france and all across europe
to help them understand
why this is happening what russia's
strategy is and what we are doing to
counter it but instead unfortunately
especially in the case of chancellor
schultz he walked right into the trap
and he spread the fear himself even
further
let me just uh briefly if you would uh
gustav come back to the situation in
donbass and how it translates
essentially into
concrete uh tactical uh goals so
if this mantra that we often hear from
eu and nato leaders that ukraine cannot
lose this war that putin cannot win this
war what would that look like
territorially are we talking about
needing to push the russians back to the
status quo ante on february 23rd or are
we talking about pushing them all the
way out of crimea for example um
actually pushing them back to february
23rd would be the minimum requirement
to tell putin or to manifest the
situation that a war of aggression did
not pay out anything short of that
is a partial territorial gain and a
further improvement of the russian
position
numerous russian leaders both military
and political already said that this is
a struggle that will uh be led for
decades to come and it is a war that
will be will russia will have to lead
over years so
they are predictable they're very blunt
in what and they tell us what they're
going to do the problem is in europe few
people listen
the problem is of course all this
announcement whether they come from the
u.s nor from from
german politicians on sort of ukraine
cannot be allowed to lose this
unfortunately are for the time being
inwards only
uh the military equipment the hardware
the ammunition uh to make this
prediction
a reality is not there the russians are
firing 50 000 rounds of artillery in all
calibers per day ukrainians have roughly
five to six thousand they are still at
their disposal
and uh the the ammunition stocks are
dwindling because
their defense industry is destroyed and
they have been in this industrial war of
attrition for
quite some time
if i hear presence that for for the next
month you have to survive with 36 000
rounds of ammunition that's what ukraine
fires in one week um i i i really and
four launchers from this country and
four launchers from that country sorry
but that's a joke so
what i'm hearing from all of you is that
any comprehensive negotiated uh peace
settlement for now is essentially
impossible and illusory nonetheless
there are particular aspects of this
conflict on which mediation is very
badly needed and meanwhile turkey's
president has in fact been casting
himself in the role of a potential
mediator and seeking to further his own
interests in the process let's take a
look domestically things are not going
well for president erdogan and his akp
his monetary policy with artificially
low interest rates is causing
hyperinflation putting many turks in
financial danger
a year ahead of the next election
erdogan and his party are at an all-time
low in the polls
so the turkish president is trying all
the more urgently to shine in other
areas
for example in foreign policy turkey
wishes to be a mediator in the struggle
to lift the russian naval blockade since
turkey controls the bosphorus it
controls the approach to the black sea
and erdogan has been blocking the
accession of sweden and finland to nato
for weeks above all to press for
concessions from its members especially
the u.s
on the one hand he is allegedly
concerned with certain american arms
deliveries but also with the possibility
that the u.s government might approve
further military intervention in
northern syria to force kurdish militias
out of the border area
how successful are erwan's attempts at
blackmail
and let me put that question right on to
uh daniel and daniel what is erdogan up
to here does he genuinely see his
country as a global player a global
mediator or is this driven by his own
personal survival strategy
but both of course um look
turkey has a lot well erdogan has a lot
to win from the situation it provides
sort of a golden opportunity for him to
stabilize his power base but on the
other hand turkey as a country has a lot
to lose turkey is much closer to the to
the situation geopolitically
in the black sea than
most of the european countries are
erdogan knows if jessica says uh our
leaders cannot read putin i think
erdogan is the one who comes the closest
in his capacities in his personal
experience his mindset to read putin and
we have seen that he has a very
ambivalent and
in in some way schizophrenic
relationship friendship with putin
because on all fronts in central asia on
the black sea in the middle east turkey
and uh and and russia are rivals they
are opponents uh they have engaged in
proxy warfare against each other but
they always found a way to balance out
their interest and they take the other
side's interest seriously furthermore i
think the
both leaders think in in the concept of
zones of influence
they consider that they're states who
have power and who are projecting power
and everyone else has to
shut up
so
what europe rejects strongly the idea
that there is zones of russian interest
like russian comfort zones that we have
to respect even though they violate the
sovereignty of other nations that is no
problem for erdogan
and uh
whatever erdogan does when you when
you're asking if he's blackmailing the
europeans or if he's blackmailing the
west for him this is tough diplomacy
this is international relations based on
interest it's not about blackmailing he
has no feeling of guilt and the turks
would always hold against the europeans
and the other nato states that they have
been involved here before they have
provided drones to the ukrainians long
before the russian assault happened long
before discussions about weapons
deliveries where also they're playing
both sides aren't they because they
don't go along with western sanctions uh
they don't go along with the sanction
that turkey's own nato allies they put
in place and yet they're selling drones
to ukraine they they it's true that they
are not going along with with western
sanctions in general but uh they are in
a way cherry-picking but they have close
turkish airspace for russian flights to
syria
they have also
said that they're going to apply the
montreal convention on the straits which
allows them theoretically to block
russian ships from the mediterranean
who are traveling to ukraine to get
involved in the conflict which is tricky
because on the one hand the russians are
allowed to return of course to their
home bases but theoretically the turks
can close the straits for russian ships
so the turks can can do a lot of harm to
russian interests in the region but they
are also very vulnerable and let's keep
that in mind that for turkey in a way
this is also a geopolitical game of
survival not only for adron himself so
on that basis jessica speaking of
shipments those grain those blockaded
grain shipments uh in ukrainian ports
time is running out a world food crisis
is looming and interestingly enough
could have very drastic repercussions
precisely in the middle east where
certainly in the past spiking feud
prices have caused political unrest
against that backdrop can you imagine
erdogan actually being the one to
unlock this
well that would be the hope but it
shouldn't and needn't come only from
erdogan you speak of erdogan holding the
west potentially hostage
with this blockage of grain exports
putin is holding
billions of people around the world who
are food insecure hostage especially in
the middle east and africa in parts of
asia facing droughts and crop failures
this crisis will become a global crisis
and the casualties of russia's invasion
of ukraine
will explode into the millions through
the indirect costs of this hunger crisis
and my hope really there would be to see
more voices from the global south more
countries and more leaders across africa
across asia and latin america and the
middle east standing up and saying
don't hold our people hostage let the
grain out and to put together perhaps a
flotia of non-nato members who are not
parties to the conflict in any way to
enable the grain to be transported
safely out and if russia blocks this if
russia does not allow the grain to be
exported peacefully
then that says everything you need to
know and any of the russian propaganda
that's trying to pin the food crisis on
ukraine and the west would be shown to
be completely bollocks daniel very
briefly yeah well that's a very
interesting phenomenon why do people in
the so-called global south not see it
that way that is it's quite interesting
i mean i don't have any statistics on
the on the on opinion polls but it seems
that the leaders in in major parts of
africa and asia south asia consider this
war a geopolitical conflict of interest
between with the west and russia
for once they are not involved but they
can just like watch what happens and
people don't in the in the global south
seem to not very much know about the
fact that russia has been reducing
exports before the onset of the war that
china has been purchasing
basically everything that was on the
market before the war so uh based on
artificial intelligence models that
probably told them that there is a risk
of grain shortage so they can capitalize
on that but it seems that the story that
russia sells to african leaders
according to which all this catastrophe
is a result of sanctions and of russia
being cut off the swift system seems to
play very well so we talked about it
last week as a battle of narratives and
uh it is very unclear who's going to win
that battle
yeah let me bring in uh gustav uh
essentially on how
far the west should go in trying to make
a deal not only with putin but with
erdogan himself erdogan is now
apparently hoping that if he were to
mediate on the grain shipments the
turkey would receive cut rate prices on
grain he's also indicated that he thinks
that uh russian demands that sanctions
on russia be partially lifted in
response to any unblocking of the grain
shipments is legitimate um
so what should the west do in this
situation and also well turk while
turkey meanwhile is holding up approval
of swedish and finnish membership in
nato a lot of cards out on this poker
table
yes uh and and our
sort of willingness to go
at least tacitly along with it uh is is
of course in bortling aragon
so first and foremost on the grains and
where ukraine sell them or give them if
they had the transport opportunity
um it's ukrainian grain it's their grain
i think we shouldn't sort of
in europe think that we can dispose it
and redistribute it
the second issue is that we need to find
other means to export them who are
sustainably secure there are some
railroad lines that export it into
poland and then into the baltic ports
but of course railway links there are
are slow there are other proposals to
export them while other
ports constanta in romania for example
that have port facilities to export and
store large amounts of grain i think
that's good
can turkey broker such a solution is
turkey an honest broker as our title
asked
jessica
turkey's in this for turkey
sometimes it's probably good to have a
mediator negotiator that represents his
or her own interest because turkey has a
lot to lose so
hope everyone uh surprises us in a good
way thanks thank you thank all of you
for being with us today and thanks to
you out there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you